قال رئيس الوزراء البريطانيه ريجيش السونا
كنا لندن ستزود اوكرانيا لالاف من ذخيره
دبابات تشالنجر على الفور كجزء من حزمه
المساعدات في بيانا ان بلاده تعمل على
اتفاقيه امنيه ثنائيه طويله الاجل مع
اوكرانيا وستسلم كييف اكثر من 70 مركبه
قتاليه
واكد ان الشركاء الدوليين يعملون على
تصعيد الترتيبات الرسميه
لحمايه اوكرانيا على المدى الطويل واكد ان
روسيا تعاني تدهورا على خطوطها الاماميه
بينما تحرز اوكرانيا تقدما استراتيجيا في
هجومها المضاد
قالت المتحدثه باسم البيت الابيض ان
ضمانات الامنيه لاوكرانيا ستعلن اليوم مع
مجموعه السبع بينما نقلت الصحيفه نيويورك
تايمز عن مسؤوليه الامريكيين واخر الاوربي
ان اداره الرئيس الامريكي جو بايدن تجري
نقاشا داخليا بشان موافقه على ارسال عدد
محدود من صواريخ ارض ارض الى اوكرانيا
وكان عدد من اعضاء مجلس النواب دعوا اداره
بايدن الشهر الماضي الى ارسال صواريخ
على الفور الى اوكرانيا لكن المسؤولين
دفاعيين حذروا من ان الترسانه الامريكيه
من هذه المنظومه صغيرا نسبيا وتستخدم بخطط
حربيه للبنتاجون في اماكن اخرى بما في ذلك
شبه الجزيره الكوريه